der mann ist über für ein skandal und
willi herren groß geworden als
schauspieler in der lindenstraße sorgt
er jetzt er mit dem ein oder anderen
skandälchen für schlagzeilen er war
nahezu in jedem promi format im
fernsehen sogar es egal ob promi boxen
dschungelcamp und so weiter und so fort
er ist immer dabei und er hat auch
erfolg als stimmungssänger sein
aktueller hit scheiß drauf mallorca ist
nur einmal im jahr da werde mit ihm
sprechen und natürlich über deutsche
grammatik und über eure fragen in den
kommentaren oder auch über eure fragen
als video antworten wenn er sie als
video antwort auf dieses video postet
info text noch gucken kreativ sein und
dann würde ich mal sagen
bis dann bleibt dran